[Music]
all right hello everyone
welcome to our
what's tonight ben prepare a prepared
prepare like a pro
prepare like a pro night uh with me and
ben simon my tormentor tonight because
there's no one's here there's a there's
the event about the uh
the 50th anniversary of a match between
uh kospar
fisher spassky
uh just right across the street and
music is out being played everybody's
having fun
it was ladies night before this there
was the wine and cheese and everything
and then now we're sitting here with ben
there's no one here and we are with you
guys going over
hippo so what's the complete name ben
i i work for this defense potemus
hippopotamus okay
yeah see that's the problem when when
you learn english as a second language
hippopotamus
okay let's see the party time so
why did i choose hippopotamus so two
reasons
first is i played in the u.s open and
those who were here last night i was
were you here last night ben you were
here
you were not no
you were not here last night no
that i went over 15 minutes and
everybody hated me here
it wasn't me it wasn't it wasn't you you
weren't here yeah
yep
so yeah i went over time so i was
covering uh
my games at the us open and how i
qualified and then i got very excited
and proud of
of my win against the ilia nizhnik and
then i went over time and people wanted
to
to leave so i kept everyone here so
uh this is my round five game and still
those who were here last night it's from
the sixth day from the traditional 90s
schedule
and uh
so
this kid john
luger or
luger right
john
beat i am
timothy taylor who was the second city
in my group
from a losing position
and i could tell he plays very fast very
intuitively has a good sense for the
game but he doesn't really calculate
much
and uh i thought okay a long game would
be good so i usually when i want a long
game sometimes sometimes i i would say
recently mostly hardly ever
i play
i play um perk modern defense so and
then he played c3
and told myself wait a second it's not
the most optimal setup against the
hippo so
so people plot them as a t so i play
knight d7
bishop e3 i played b6
knight d2 guys i just want to say if he
goes bishop c4 i must go here e6 because
if i go
this way he's got some nasty stuff going
on
yeah
yeah not fun
not fun ben
although wait a second does it work
actually
maybe it doesn't work actually
96 let's see
i'm just being lazy let me just see does
this work or is it winning for
oh my god it doesn't work huh
it doesn't work so that that nasty stuff
doesn't work actually i could just get
away with it huh doesn't work
okay
that's all right
so
anyways he didn't play 29 d2 bishop b7
bishop c4 and i went e6 actually this is
a very good setup against this this this
system
castle knight e7 rookie one h6
just
playing the most queen c2 castle
knight f1 and here
okay a6 a4 was included here i really
just could play d5
and i got a very good position i mean
normal e takes d5 knight comes to d5
then i play c5 and queen c7
fully developed bishops pieces pieces in
the game but i just wasn't so sure what
to do after this because now if i was a
threat
so i must take on e4
and i wasn't sure that if
this simplified position which i saw and
the engine approves is something i want
to play after c5 it's just white is too
solid and i needed complications because
i needed to win the game
so then i played the move uh
c5 which is not a great move and i was
aware of it
with bishop d3 play queen c7
played queen d2 as you can see is making
normal moves and they're all good
because if i don't go d5 and he
and the hippo that's one of the problems
that's why we are slaying
hippo tonight
ben that's why that's why we're trying
to say don't play hippo
is that legal
what's that slain the hippo
uh it's a good question
it's a good question i didn't think
about it that way uh slaying the hippo
well not in africa probably but it
probably works here yeah oh dear
or maybe
wait do they have hippos in savannah
in georgia
no maybe in a zoo
a zoo
okay
well i haven't been on
safari
like only have been once in dubai and
that was like a long time ago and they
don't have people there so
but next next time i see hippo i
wouldn't i won't slay him and just say
that's just for being fine ben simon can
find what my god
well truth hurts that's for being final
that one is for mainframe gold okay
c5
yeah
so c5
bishop d3 well the good thing that no
one's here is that we i can joke with
ben that's a good part that's the that's
yeah no one's watching no one's
okay queen c7 queen d2 king h7 of course
the queen d2 was attacking the pawn on
h6
king h7
and h4 okay it sees i mean it makes a
lot of sense this move although it
probably doesn't address the needs of
the position he's just trying to play
the move h5
and he's just kind of using this x-ray
somehow but he was playing this very
fast this moves he wasn't calculating he
was playing intuitively so i played e5
which i have to
close the close bishop
play knight g3 knight f6 as well i mean
knight h2 and then
here i'm all right i think if i run the
engine i have
i have i have a number of ways to play
this position and i can tell you what
what crossed my mind so you take twice
the knight c6 doesn't move
um
knight fg8 okay that this is a weak
engine dude that didn't cross my mind
this was what crossed my mind
and uh
yeah i didn't like this queen d8 bishop
c3 because whenever i move this knight
takes the bishop and if i go knight e5
he just continues with this fight
actually i thought about rookie one in
the game which is still good yeah
so i really asked okay el-shan you're in
trouble your position is bad so only
thing that i can rely on is that i can
complicate things so i just captured and
i played knight c6
he went okay c1 queen d8 so this time i
keep keep keep the pawn on the board
keeps the pawns d and c on the board and
after d5 we have a sort of a benoni
position i still had to go 95 i knew
that i had to go knight d5 but then his
responses are
again easy because here he wants to go
f4 h5 it's so easy to play as as as
white so one knight a5
threatening to go to b3 he
spend the tempo playing queen e2 yes he
had better responses here i played 97
attacking this pawn and looking at this
move he played h5 also normal move i
played knight d5 which is a mistake
which is a mistake i had to go back
queen h4 or something else or whatever
but my position was bad so i was just
playing fast
he responded fast as you can see it's
not a great move he could just play here
f4
that's just it just takes knight g4 just
attack against g6 is too strong and my
position just goes down really fast
so he went back bishop b1 this one show
very quickly this part of the game he
played knight f1
i played b5 which is a mistake again
because and this is the beautiful part
of it that you have to see
okay not a b5 here
not hg62 sorry not not that capture
uh
here you can play
f4
knight ec4
and uh
knight f3 very strong response so if i
go back there's e5 and if i take here
knight is g3 traps my queen because
queen g for loses to knight g5 check
you following ben
yes yes of course
so
uh he took and then there was this
beautiful moment should i give people
time to think about positions or not
if you'd like we have a bear never
watching
okay all right guys
black to play this is a beautiful tactic
i missed and it's a beautiful one how
about if i give them three four minutes
four minutes
four minutes it is okay
in the meantime just abide
i should ask for a cut from the coin
brothers for the big lebowski i just
keep walking
talking about it
so this beautiful tactic i missed
hey ryan how are you
wonderful it's good
we're live you want to join us
there's a beautiful tactic here
it's not wine but it's still nice
it's not wine but it's nice
all right
well i don't blame you i don't blame you
for not being here so
[Music]
okay we don't i don't see in the chat is
are they active or something is coming
up in the chat or no
they're here i guess they're thinking
okay
suggestions okay
okay team pressed okay bishop a6
capture
capture here of course and then
queen back to d2
thinking okay
let them think a little bit a couple of
minutes
music is very nice outside
ben
yeah they got a dj out there that's
great
should we go dancing after
no well unfortunately it all ends in 13
minutes in 13 minutes there yeah
no that goes on to that goes on to nine
the dj thing goes until eight but the
the event goes until nine is that right
yes that's right yeah
yes bishop takes g2
king takes g2
and then
i'll not not capture no no no if you
captured there it takes king and the
knight of three are down the pieces
still
neither three right away
attacking the knight and the queen must
capture queen g for check it's a very
important move and then king get fun
rook takes f3 and the king can not run
away because the rook clicks have to
check capture rook f8 chicken the king
is either the closer loss of material or
uh
or checkmate so and otherwise the threat
is this this mate is coming
and if queen d1 bishop takes p2
uh
rook c2 check
check
check
and this follows okay good one don't
want to spend so much time training
tactics oops what was that by the way
the mate is right here and beautiful
where's the mate
[Music]
where's the mate
um just maybe check here
check here
now that runs away
bring it back over there where's the
mate guys
maybe this check huh
ben where's the mate okay
where is where is the money lebowski i
think this is it yeah i'm just gonna oh
okay too my god
this is embarrassing
this is this is completely embarrassing
where's the mate i just
because queen here he goes rook b2
okay maybe there is no mate
but queen a7 just goes goes king takes
d6
do you miss this in the game
i missed much earlier than this but
okay takes
check okay this queen 87 check ah queen
e7 shaking c6
oh queen i don't see the main oh my god
i saw this position and then i didn't
see queen a6 oh that's embarrassing
yep
the first candidate to finish last in
the u.s championship i mean come on i
didn't see that all right
i was just looking at they should be
made in fact when i looked at queen xe4
i i thought i saw a mate
but just it just kind of got blurry in
my head
i am
okay anyways uh not much wasting your
time he played queen a4 i played knight
c4 played this move not a great move and
after this i got initiative and
gradually i converted but what we can
see is that my position sucked for the
most part let's just face it
so
then i thought about okay wait a second
what's my experience with with with this
with this system
from white side oh i won this easy game
against uh timor garif
and uh let me show you that one
and even it was without any prep let me
let me just save it
and let me show you that one too uh
so yeah
so this was i was on the white side i
already had lost my game one against
someone who played some some hybrid
system of hippo t ron patricia and
another world champion another
uh armenian grand master
so we play this and it's kind of like a
hippo this one bishop c4 bishop g7 so i
play it's very solid
and he's just trying to get the hippo
this time even in a more
in a more uh aggressive way because
where's my where's my chat here's my
chest
yep
um so here i played the same way but
then here i came up with this very nice
concept because i was very i was very
focused during the game so i came up
with this very nice concept
because now after h5 i found this very
beautiful maneuver g390 i was so proud i
was so proud look at this let me just
run the engine
and this is a this i play in 2016 or
even before that look at it look at this
look at this
uh-huh
i'm too good too good ben simon
yep
anyways
so i played this and then i just
developed my pieces and the lack of
space due to hippo
hippo uh
the let's i just develop my pieces push
the push the pawns get the space
weakening his position
look at this nice i mean
completely out of the game
really was one of my better games
when i was a pro when i was still a
professional so there
a6 i went there
king h80 is trying to waste some time
bishop f2 just making sure my pieces are
good and look at this again these three
pieces are just out of the game
completely out of the game and any piece
sacrifice wouldn't get anywhere
d takes e5 and then finally i just
just again made making sure because he
wants me to train some sacrifice also it
was a rapid game
there there rook t1
maintaining my pressure the next coming
is not this is this is my next plan
right
went there and rooked his he he fell for
this and then
he was so bad that he resigned you know
just
it's just black has absolutely no
counter play
anyways
this was a nice crushing win and i was
very happy about it at the time so then
i thought oh wait a second
hip hip
hypopotamus doesn't really
do much for for black and if white
nosebox is doing
and well i'm lucky i want this game with
black but let's just see
what this opening is about actually so i
i searched for the main line
and
i'm sure many people have
have had this one covered
but
since i work with the
i think a publisher and
in one of the books uh iwani for bible
justin tan grand master
had this one kind of covered i checked
it i liked it
uh there are a few things that may not
have liked it as much but uh
but i'm going to cover it here uh so
most of these are his his analysis some
of it are some of we don't mind
extending it
so this is the the typical the tabia the
position of hippopotamus let me okay
yeah
and knight d7 uh b5 is very interesting
actually it's one of the lines that the
book covers
really nicely and finds this key idea
before because i'm i'm
i'm blocking the pawn and i'm adding the
uh
the
how do you how do you pronounce this
l-i-v-e-r lever
letter no no sorry l-e-v-a-r
not the organ lever lever yes using the
lever there
yeah
lever yes
yeah yeah
okay so
so
yeah and then a4 is coming it's not as
obvious i mean the the evaluation in the
book says here what is clearly better i
was i would
say it's what is slightly better
um because black has some sort of like
an active plan it needs a bit of a
clarification so this was my third
analysis of a correspondence game
so
it goes up to this point then going back
to c7 because queen takes
e4 just runs into knight d4 and then
bishop of three is coming knight c6 is
just this coin is very uncomfortable
including
and including the fact that black is not
developed on the queen side
is he's having a
hard time so in fact more than a hard
time is just completely lost
um so must play queen back c7 knight d2
defending the pawn bishop b7 and if you
just play it on with extra pawn
black has obvious compensation with with
active with active bishops and active
pieces and this knight is not really
fantastically placed so in the game
white player p1
which my engine works showed that
actually it's not that's great i'll
remove so a5 is my novelty over this
correspondence
game pinning down this pawn on a
over here then
probably some sort of an f3 knight c4 is
coming and
if you work on it must be winning for
white
so
that's for b5 and if and if the move uh
b6 is being played you just develop the
pieces and you just kind of get another
transposition to the main line
excuse me
now um knight e7 was played
queen d2
h6
okay e1 just
i like i like the way the book
approaches this kind of position it's
it's very much in accordance to my
chess philosophy a lot of life
philosophy to just not tonight because
we're not joining a party but i always
i'm about to bring the dudes to the
party always go to the i'll have always
have everyone in the party
all the dudes must be in the party so
and if
g5 then it's the same as the my game
against gary if you go h4 g4 knight h2
h5
now black's play on the king side is
completely suppressed and stopped with
this good prophylactic play and then you
just expand on the queen side and you
just enjoy the extra space you have b6
bishop g5 there d5
and you just yeah this is just really
black doesn't i don't know what to do
next this i have very simple improvement
moves which
which
which puts
uh white ahead in almost everything
so that's for g5 that's uh so b6 must be
played rook a d1 bishop b7
um
h3 just another way to move the thing is
that now now here
black has some some problem because uh
cannot castle you cannot cast the king's
side because the pawn 96 is on pres
actually i have to make it red
and uh so i have to try to do something
so i either can't play g5 b5 or actually
march this king over here
or that's very
seems very artificial but actually it's
been tried before
so let's look at the move
g5 first
all right let me give everyone
ben how about three minutes huh
what do they what do you think what plan
will you come up with for here for white
it's one of the critical ideas that they
have to know
okay let me get to the chat because
where's the chat that's here's my chat
when was this gameplay this is not a
game this is theory
okay
two more minutes
this plan is very important to know this
is a like you need to know few ideas for
for white ones that in b5 you have b4 a4
here when they go g5 this is a very
important one we will see in the next
game of neptune that
he missed the win at the end but how he
executed the right plan against vayi
ben what do you play in this position
you don't know
will you resign no no you have not
resigned are you sure
yes okay
that works for me
it's a bit
uh
well we have mr tim priest uh here and
we are we are we are here quoting the
chess bible so that kind of is very
ironically cool
so uh
uh tim uh if knight is f4 is a bit slow
we go d5 that's a very important
movement to know not know
because if they go e5 now i have these
scores all weekend because of the move
g5 that's why they moved d5 is very
strong against
what against uh against g5 because if
you can and now in either two now i have
all these scores so you have to include
the move d5 at first because if they go
moves like for example knight g6 knight
d4 pressuring and now he must take on d
for otherwise you have all these jumps
for example one with d e6 bishop h5 and
opening the game and because your pieces
or dudes are in the party
blacks are not he's gonna have a problem
knife f5 that's also coming yes
so yeah this is going to be extremely
nasty for for black taking okay this is
better but still this bishop is
misplaced because it's not all
suppressed and blocked and you really
need this special over here by the time
you try to do that
um the book says this but i mean you can
all even play this move and then try to
be g3 bishop goes to f5 g3 kick the
knight
it's all good
so that g5 is is going to be met with
d5
now uh we talked about that if knight f6
trying to pressure bishop d3 b5 a3 just
to stop that but now black doesn't have
the breakthroughs either c black needs
one of these moves one of these forms to
get some space oh sorry that's illegal
and not none of them works
so yes it's not collapsing but now after
knight h2 now because he hasn't played
any of those
space gaining moves we have knight h2 f4
then we improve a little bit and then
finally
we have queen f1 right there h4 all the
tactics worked i i don't want to
bore you i i don't think it will bore
you but i mean
this there's queen e5 i mean engine was
saying castle let me see why queen e5 is
not working i forgot to mention that
i mean there is some
jesus c3 okay
that wasn't easy i should have i should
have included that
all right that is
above everyone's paycheck that's the
engine's paycheck
and we win the queen
but this advantage is not is not
tangible enough in my opinion it still
has some work has to be done here
anyways yeah
anyways all right so
this was black's best play in my opinion
knight history is the books
recommendation so that's for knight f6
so if you are playing it as black my
recommendation is go knight f6
because other ones black has clear white
has clear plan like if you tried the
king f81
there there 92 i'm just bringing my
pieces over here king h79 g3 c5 c3
capture capture knight f6
bishop f4 rook f8 okay he got the
artificial castle link but now you can
just play like mr john luger which is
what guys what did john lugar do against
me
hmm
what did john luger do against me
let me give everyone three minutes here
to think about it
so
okay
guys
you were here
we all saw
john lugar was winning against me
um
okay let me just give it one more time
h4
just go for the x-ray
knight g4
no no no
queen to just maintain the pressure
king g8 h5 not the move g5 is not
obviously working because of this
capture
and if captured back then
this this this
it's
painful
there and then e5 and bishop c4 is also
equally good the book suggests e5 and
then white opens up all of white's
pieces are in there in attack there's a
massive pressure on on black's king
engine is only giving plus one in this
position but that's for the engines over
the board it looks like just game over
black's king looks very busted
all right so that's for king f8
i still don't find this as compellingly
winning but it's still good enough
and i think that's what the engines also
suggest so and everybody likes to go by
the engine's choice
and i mean given that you know all my
pieces are kind of a little bit cramped
here
that's the best way i could unwind my
pieces so
give this credit to this to this plan
and b5
and now this time i go d5 this is the
only time we meet b5 because now he's
ready to play knight b6 this is the only
time because my rook has already
departed from a1 that i faced b5 with
the move d5 this is the only time
and after e5 there is this very
beautiful positional idea for white
regrouping very very nice deep idea that
white plays and that secures advantage
for what in this position if you do not
play this move black can end up on top
so you really have to be careful
knowing this position and knowing this
move so i'm going to give everyone
another 30 minutes hmm
ben what do you say i have three mr
people
i don't know because i want people to
get engaged in it and it seems that we
don't get much in the chat so
whatever i feel like that is the right
amount of time
i mean you kind of have to think about
it i i
had the engine running i had the book in
my hand and uh
i kind of know this kind of position
because i play against kings and i have
played kings indiana's black but
all right three minutes it is
it is like just shut up and continue
that's the look on his face
um
well this is very important
so someone says be like andrew
who is andrew tate
is he chess player
maybe you meant immortate
the international russia
yeah
it looks like he also went by andrew k
okay
oh really i didn't know that okay
i okay wait hold on i'm totally confused
because
if you google andrew tay
you come up with a social media
influencer and former professional
kickboxer but his name was emery tate
uh
not too sure that's the everything
we're talking about team says yes that's
the song
okay
okay a rather
character character apparently i don't
know
i i don't i don't follow guys on social
media i mean the only guys i'm the only
people i'm following are
ben simon
and sabino right
those are the only people i'm following
on the social media
and my cat
and regina
well i kind of have to follow my mom too
because she made me but
not before tim b5 is
coming wow
i learned something cool
you see
if it wasn't for tonight and if you were
over there we would never learn about
android android tate
you see how important was that to be
here tonight
ben
now g4 is still just too much so it's
it's indeed you loosening bishop d3 very
strong move
this move opens the file in case of f5
eyeballing this is square
and freeze this is square for the
knights it's a very multi-purpose strong
move here
so if he goes f5 now capture capture
knight h4 f4 bishop takes f4 and now
having the file open is a decisive
factor
um yet knight g6 is coming uh or bishop
g6 so many good moves here
uh
so
knight b6 would be played
a4 now takes and rook a1 is a good move
92 i mean anything is good knight e2 was
suggested in the book i like that move
c6
detects c6 knight takes c6 not back to
c3 i'm going to win that pawn with rook
a1
knight d4 and here comes another very
strong move in the book very engine-like
move
uh
this is a hard one i'm gonna give
three minutes on this one
then after that we could just make a
small wrap up on this and then
i'll show you one one thematic game
and now you know how to slay
the opening
hyperbotamas
so
i'm not into this whole gravity thing so
no more hippo huh
i'm just gonna be
very
very thorough
that's for sure
uh
okay
i think it's a little bit difficult the
move is bishop f1 next clam and that's
uh
that is credit to the book good job
knight takes f3 gtx f3
and now d6 is hanging must play back and
then rk1 attacking the pawn bishop there
and f4 so black is up a pawn
but he just cannot develop for example
the move if e5 is coming maybe and
knight d5 is coming
but
if you are watching this video and you
get into this position
you are wrong if you just look at this
position and just walk away while he's
better no you need to spend some time
with the engine winning from this
position this is a plus one for engines
i don't understand what the plus one is
for like starfish 15.
the uh
the the measure the uh i don't know the
gauge like the like in the uh
uh
in a car has been really manipulated in
the past years and the word advantage
plus one which used to mean one pawn or
just like close to winning or something
like that they mean different things so
engine can say oh he's winning but we
don't understand why and the measures
are being really altered to the way that
the engines can play better to the
engines would understand its own
evaluation better
so
will i say what is clearly better in a
very human sense yes but you have to
spend the time to learn it
not you then you don't don't learn it
okay don't slay the hippos don't don't
just stay away from them
no safari for for you in a long time to
have to africa
we send you where do you want me to send
send you singapore maybe for example huh
how does that sound no that's okay
that's okay
you'd like to go to tokyo we sent ben to
tokyo fantastic
we sent ben to tokyo
i'm actually going to new zealand myself
that's great yeah i'm going to new
zealand in
january 1st i mean i'll arrive there on
january 1st yes so i go to newsland we
sent we sent ben to tokyo no safari for
me no no no safari for ben just
yeah are you gonna have a new year's
toast on the plane
yes oh interesting i've had that once
before to fly out of las vegas to
frankfurt interesting yes i've had that
before too once
so i'm not new to it that was my first
trip as an as an american
that was very memorable
first time leaving the country as an
american felt great
that was the first time they were asking
me what they were they did not ask me
where i come from and what's the purpose
of my visit it felt really good just
saying
so
uh yeah this is a very good position so
yeah this file i'm i mean you guys don't
share files right but i mean they can
they can see the moves i kind of put
almost everything here
and i'm gonna wrap up just by showing a
quick game of nipponyachi against the
against the vayi
and
we send we send you guys chasing hippos
so
we have the position
well it started with a4 this time but
you know the ideas now so this queen d2
h6 h3 g5 so we said against g5 what did
we do guys
we got d5 always g5 is met with d5 and
then that's what that's what uh
that's what nippon knew just pretty well
there there and knight is still now
going forward for these squares again
man i i think i made a career out of
this thing i'm these squares like
if you know how many games i have won in
kings india winning against these weak
squares
there
i mean be my guess taking because i can
just reinforce i capture f3 knight goes
here
bishop of five there g3
okay so now uh he tries to complicate
things because i cannot go g takes f4
because gtx4 runs into g takes back f4
so
he goes f3
ah team i'm not bullying the king's
indian i was a kings indiana player
myself tim
just
it's it's a very difficult opening
that's all i'm saying for example there
is uh this player grand master theodoro
from greece he's he's doing a great job
playing it
but if you're not
prepared to the tea
i'm sorry i have to say it's it's it's
it doesn't it's not gonna work you're
either a guy like theodoro catronias
these guys like the greeks are really
good at kings indian the greek
grandmasters
top-notch players i don't know glitching
used to play but i don't know
wasn't easy to follow krishuk
um
we almost don't see it in the above 2700
level
um
rook g8
king h1
yeah it's it's just very hard to play
and then g takes f4 so
they was playing all in
and uh he plays some tactics here
capture capture queen g5 throw the sink
at his opponent and here
nepal needed a draw to qualify so he let
his opponent
give perpetual
but
how does white win this position
white has a winning move here so the
game continued if i show it it will show
the
if i show the move it will show the
other alternative he played 93 in the
game but 93 is not the winning move
it's a very hard move actually i have to
add it to my to my content for my
students
a very interesting move here
you can find it with the price of
elimination
so
ben found it huh
up
so what i know is what i know i need is
that i have to bring the queen to defend
the king because remember i'm up two
pieces but i'm facing the mating threat
over here on g2 so i'm gonna play
should we wrap it up pen or give him
some more time
good job tim wow he found it
good job tim yes now bishop h4 emily
just take it and then it comes in bishop
b6
capture
now bishop g3 also takes this and then
queen f2
sorry sorry my bad not going after
knight h2 first
because if he takes we take back then we
simply consolidate with queen d390 394
knight f3 and just
control all the light squares and he
doesn't have any play
oh we should show this for you there's a
mate it's a mate bishop which four now i
was talking about the knight bishop g3
we take it
that's what that means we take it bishop
bishop leaving there yeah there's a mate
on g1 you cannot leave that one too
bishop e3 runs do the same thing
oh my god i'm so tired
what they're laughing at
no because the thing is when i have
blunder
ben it feels very bad when i blunder
mate it feels very bad
what's that i understand
no what's what you're laughing at
just
you're very tired
no it's not that it's it's just it feels
bad when i when i didn't mention the
queen g1 mate it feels bad
you know during the during the stream
today i missed a few mates
i i won all my games actually in the
stream
but i just was missing it and i was
continuously you know when you played
two hours the first hour i was playing
sharp good games fun games you know
there were things to play things both
players would miss but then some coffee
i already had a lot of coffee today i
think i i've had i have i've had a lot
but thanks for tim
i think it's too late for coffee at at
8 25. so
so
yeah and then i started hanging mate
hanging queen and stuff like that i'm
like oh my god what's wrong with me and
that feeling i'm talking about not not
just the fatigue or being tired i mean
everybody gets tired at the end of the
day but
that thing that you mismade
and you haven't done enough tactics that
feels it just
it's just you know guys
you feel like you're losing your mojo
it's a killer you're losing your when
you feel like you're losing your mojo
man
i feel so
so done
it it feels worse than anything
yeah when i play good chess i feel alive
you know just this is this is me doing
my thing and then when i don't uh
but i have to accept it you know
it comes with the age and the fact that
i'm not a professional player anymore
anyways bishop b6 is the movie he played
knight d3 and after this
consider to the perpetual check the game
in the draw okay i hope you guys had fun
we slayed
the hippopotamus if you want a good good
account on that
check the hippopotamus part uh
hippopotamus
part oh my god this i'm too tired even
to pronounce it correctly
of course tim
uh
are we getting existential here no i i
am a stoicist what are you talking about
man
i am a i'm a tourist yes a slash
hedonist
no don't don't label me epicorian may be
maximum you can
get along with me
yeah mostly if accordion
so
yes
that is me
uh i hope you guys had fun
if you want to check the book i think
the the content the book is very solid
about this one i'm sure other books have
similar stuff too as well but
this one i got it from club i checked it
it was solid very solid there are a few
things that you can improve but all in
all i give it a good pass if you want to
slay
hippo
we'll have some other some other
questionable openings next time
and hopefully
with some audience here too without
being ben simon yes
plus me
plus
what's that plus me plus you okay plus
vince simon well
well
it's me and ben now okay
signing off huh
voila voila have a good night everyone
take care
[Music]
you